foreign
T the amphibious Robot Turtle as its
name suggests art is a robot that can
swim in water and walk on land and it's
all down to a clever party trick
it has legs that can turn into flippers
according to the team of researchers
behind the bot this shape-shifting
ability has the potential to make art
more efficient than existing amphibious
machines so some robot designers will
say okay
we know propellers work you know well in
water to move around we know Wheels work
well on land so let's make a robot put
propellers on it and we've put wheels on
it and water a propeller might be very
efficient but on land
um it doesn't really
allow the robot to move but it ends up
being additional weight on the robot
additional space this is where art makes
its efficiency gains instead of having
separate components to move in water and
on land Arts morphing limbs can adapt to
suit both removing the need for
redundant parts
so these are the two modes of the
morphing limb so on my right here we
have the flipper mode which is this flat
hydrodynamic shape
and then on my left here we have the leg
mode which is this shape cylindrical and
load bearing and we have a little
curvature on the end of the limb that
gives it some surface area so that it
can contact the ground and not not just
fall over
creating this limb required some
principles from the rapidly growing
field of Soft Robotics on the outside
there's a balloon that inflates and
gives the limit shape and on the inside
bonded to this balloon is a material
that changes its stiffness when it's
heated up past a certain temperature
it becomes very soft and pliable and so
using these materials we can transition
from The Flipper to the leg or from the
leg to The Flipper that can walk on land
or swim in water or transition between
the two
creating adaptable limbs was just the
first step next they needed to program
art with patterns of movement known as
gates to make use of these morphing
materials and for inspiration as you
might have guessed they turned to
Turtles and their terrestrial
counterparts tortoises
so the walking gate is called a creeping
gate this isn't the fastest gate but
it's similar to a tortoise so if you
look at a tortoise they have sort of
this amble where they're lifting their
legs up slowly one by one and this is
what this creeping gate was inspired by
so we also have a gate that's inspired
more by for example sea turtles and this
is
the quintessential flapping motion you
would see a sea turtle doing sort of a
quasi figure eight pattern in which the
flipper is coming up and then coming
down and it's changing it's it's angled
with respect to the the forward
Direction all the while
these two gates seem to do the job well
on land and in water but art ran into
some difficulty on the awkward terrain
between the two environments which is
often Sandy Stony or muddy and art often
slipped or got stuck so the team opted
for another less elegant solution so we
looked at peaching sea turtles and
basically The Locomotion strategy they
use which is lying on their stomachs and
then pulling themselves forward and is
not particularly graceful but Shifting
the gate really gave us a little more
versatility in where the robot could go
the researchers calculated metrics for
Arts efficiency by measuring how much
power it used and how fast it was able
to move for its weight in different
settings and armed with its morphing
Limbs and shifting Gates art was able to
match or outperform many exclusively
terrestrial or exclusively aquatic
robots while still being able to move in
both environments
of course art is still a work in
progress right now for example it's
tethered meaning its power supply and
programming Center aren't housed within
the body itself but in the future the
team hopes that morphing amphibious Bots
loaded with sensors or cameras like you
can see here could be used for things
like ecological monitoring or even
Disaster Response and their
shape-shifting approach to robot design
doesn't have to stop there so I don't
think it's necessarily confined to just
a robot with morphing limbs this idea
can be extended where we have
robot bodies that morph more drastically
to specialize for different types of
locomotion different tasks
I think if people see the potential
efficiency gains shape morphing and
lends itself to adaptability in a
variety of robotic applications
[Music]